[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN MCGRATH: So thanks for
coming into the session.
I want to give you a quick
overview of what we're going
to talk about in this session.
So for the people in the room
who are new to Cloud Firestore,
I'm going to give you
an introduction on what
it gives you, why we built
the particular product.
And then I'm going to
jump into what's new.
So I've got a couple of exciting
announcements of new features
and functionality we're
launching for Firestore,
so we'll cover that.
Then we'll go through
some common architectures
that we've seen during
our beta program
from actual customers who
are using the products, some
of them who are
in the room today.
And then Kathy
will come back on,
talk about how Google
itself is using
Cloud Firestore for an
application you might all
be familiar with.
And then give a quick
demo and look at some
of the code behind that demo.
And then I'll come
back on, we'll
talk a little bit
about scaling tips.
And then we'll
probably do a Q&A if we
have enough time at the end.
So to start, let me talk
a little bit about what
this session is really about.
It's really about
helping you understand
how to build scalable apps
using GCP and Firebase.
And in particular, using the
Cloud Firestore database.
Just to kick things
off, can I find out,
in this room, who has
used Firebase Real-time
Database before?
And who has used Cloud
Datastore before?
And who has already played
with Cloud Firestore?
I might need to get some of you
to come do the presentation.
There's actually a lot of
people in here, that's awesome.
So I want to start by painting
a picture or an architecture
of something that I would
have used to have done.
Let's say you're in a
company and you're building
a new mobile web application.
How would you go about building
that in a traditional way?
You would start off with a web
server for your static content.
Then you might have a
dedicated application server
for the dynamic content
that's changing and mutating
as your users are using it.
You probably have a database
server running somewhere,
running on some sort
of persistent storage.
Then you're probably thinking
about adding in replications
so you can do maintenance
without having
to bring everything down.
Maybe give yourself some high
availability capabilities.
It's not too hard to add.
And then as your app starts
to get more successful,
you're probably thinking
about disaster recovery
and how would you build that?
Now you're worrying about
a standby data center.
You've got VPNs and
carrier interconnect byte
that you're building.
At this point, you've got some
pretty heavy infrastructure
that you've built and you've
got full-time people maintaining
that infrastructure.
Well, what we want
to do is give you
tooling that abstracts
that away and gives you
something where you can
focus on just the app
that you're writing.
So with Cloud Firestore
and some of our products
that we have in the
Firebase platform,
we can simplify that
final architecture
that I showed you with
a very simple setup.
You can use Cloud Firestore
directly from your devices.
And you can use Firebase
Hosting for storing and serving
the static content.
And you can use Firebase Auth to
give you that secure interface
into it.
And then finally, you
can use Cloud Functions
to expand into the many other
tools that we have within GCP.
So when we built
Cloud Firestore,
we really believed in giving
tooling so that small teams can
accomplish big things.
And by providing
those small teams
with powerful yet simple
tools that get out of the way,
we can give them a
foundation for success.
And lastly, we want to make
sure this tooling is available
everywhere.
So let's start off with some
of the basics behind Firestore.
So we have Firebase
SDKs that we've
integrated with that give you
native client libraries on iOS,
web, and Android.
We integrate with
Firebase Authentication
to handle the authentication
into the server.
We have a declarative
security rules language
to allow you to control access
to your data based on not just
the properties of
the signed in user,
but also, the information
in its database itself.
We give you Cloud
Functions to integrate
into the rest of the platform.
And we also use Firebase
Hosting as a convenient way
to serve up content.
Now, it is expected
in apps today
that they just work
across mobile and web.
You may not have
intended this to happen,
but it's a basic expectation
most people have today,
that they can pick
up their phone
and continue using what
they were using on the web.
And sometimes even use both
of them at the same time.
There's a further
expectation, which, perhaps,
some people in the audience
have discovered today,
that network connectivity
is not always available.
There are environments, even
in our hyper-connected world,
where you need to have offline
capabilities in your app.
And we've built a lot
of tooling around this
to make it simple
to enable these use
cases in your application.
Further to that, we know people
are building some very complex
applications on our tooling, so
we have a full suite of server
client libraries, including
C#, Go, Java, Python, PHP.
These particular toolings
allow you to use our serverless
database in a way that is truly
scalable, regardless of what
architecture you want to use.
We have got a multi-region
replicated database
to make sure its always
reliable and available for you,
and I'll talk a little bit
about that in a second.
So just to finish off the
actual database itself
in this quick intro, I
want to talk about how
the data is structured.
So we spent a lot of time with
the real-time database people
to understand how people
are using their data,
and what ways they want
to naturally use it.
For Cloud Firestore, we're using
the collection and document
model that allows you to
store related data together
in a semi-structured fashion.
So let's quickly talk
about what is new.
And these are all coming
shortly, starting in August,
and then rolling
out through 2019.
So the first one
that I want to talk
about, Cloud Firestore is going
to have a lot of new locations
launched.
So currently, we have
a multi-region location
in the US.
And starting next
month, we're going
to gradually roll out the
full suite of locations
that you see here.
Whether it's in the Americas,
Europe, or Asia-Pacific,
you're going to
be able to locate
your database and your
data closest to where
your particularly user base is.
We are also announcing--
and this is of interest
to the Cloud Datastore
customers in the room--
that Cloud Firestore
is now going
to support Datastore mode.
Cloud Firestore is designed
as the third generation
of Cloud Datastore.
And it's going to support all
the existing APIs and client
libraries that you use today.
We are going to seamlessly
upgrade every one,
so you don't need
to change your code
and you don't need to
worry about downtime
to get the properties that
we have in this new system.
Some of those properties I
will go into in a second,
but they include things like
being strongly consistent
for all queries, and having
a five nines availability
SA once we get to GA.
The beta for this new
mode starts in August.
So you're probably
asking, what's the catch?
So let me talk about
a couple of the things
we're removing in Datastore
mode for Cloud Datastore users.
The first thing
that we're removing
is the entity group
restrictions you have today.
So no longer will you
be limited to one write
per second per entity group to
get strongly consistent data.
So hopefully, this is a good
thing we have removed for you.
The second one is
you no longer need
to use ancestor queries to
have strong consistency.
All queries across
Cloud Datastore,
when you're using Cloud
Firestore in the new Datastore
mode, will be
strongly consistent.
And the last thing
we're removing
is the 25 entity group
limit for transactions.
It doesn't matter how
many entity groups
you use in Cloud Datastore, we
will support the transactions
for it.
Just want to quickly
touch on the upgrade,
because I know a lot
of you who have got
Cloud Datastore
databases are wondering
how this is going to happen.
So we are doing the
upgrade for you.
The Google engineering
team is going
to be live migrating the
information from Cloud
Datastore to Datastore
mode without any downtime.
We will send announcements out
about this to our user base
in the coming weeks.
There is no action
required on your behalf.
We are going to
handle everything.
There are no code changes
that you need to do.
And all the existing
functionality APIs and client
libraries you use
will still work.
If you want to
play with it early,
you can create new databases
during our beta period.
And once we get to GA,
we will start upgrading.
So I just wanted to
quickly point out some
of the differences in case
you're wondering when you would
use Datastore mode-- it's
the new mode we're announcing
today--
and native mode, which
is the existing mode
Cloud Firestore users
have been using in beta.
There's a couple of minor
terminology differences
between them.
Datastore mode is designed
as that server-side database,
and the native mode is designed
as your backend-as-a-service
for your mobile, web,
and IoT applications.
When you think about Datastore,
think about a NoSQL database
that scales from zero to
a million writes a second.
When you think
about Native mode,
think about a
backend-as-a-service that
scales from zero to a million
concurrent connections from
your devices.
We have also just
published our draft SLA.
So this is the SLA that will go
into effect once we get to GA.
For our multi-region
locations, it's
five nines of availability.
And for our regional
locations, it's
four nines of availability.
This system is designed to make
sure your app is up and running
when you need it.
In August, we are also
releasing managed exports
for native mode.
So this will allow you to take
a full export of your data
into GCS and import it
back into your project
if you need to recover
some of that data.
Or perhaps, import it into
another project, a dev or a QA
environment.
You can also take these exports
and import them into BigQuery
so you can use a full SQL
language to do ad hoc reporting
against that data.
We have also added the
data viewer for native mode
into GCP's console.
So starting in August, you
will see a new Firestore tab
where you can see our live
updating UI to manipulate
and query against your data.
We are also adding a
new set of functionality
around managing your indexes.
So for those who haven't
used Cloud Firestore before,
we automatically index all
your fields in your document.
Sometimes, you want
more control over that,
and so we've got
a new system that
allows you to selectively turn
on and off particular types
of indexes for your document.
For those people who
have got sharp eyes,
you may have seen a new indexing
mode down the bottom, called
array contains.
So Cloud Firestore will now be
able to do containment queries
against arrays.
And I just saw a little fist
bump, so that's a good sign.
So now I want to talk about
some of the common architectures
I've seen with customers
who have been using
Cloud Firestore successfully.
The first one I want to
talk about is Guesswork.
Guesswork is a machine
learning startup
for helping e-commerce
companies in emerging markets.
They recommend new products
for first time buyers
on their site.
When a new user
arrives on the site,
Guesswork collects a whole bunch
of datapoints about that user,
where they're coming from.
Did they come from an email
campaign or a fashion website?
And including other things
like the geographic region
and the device type.
They then come up
with a recommendation
based on this user.
And the data can take
a couple of paths
to get back to the user.
So let's have a
quick look at one
of the examples they did
with a company called Zalora
in Southeast Asia,
to bring better
e-commerce recommendations
to their customers.
So to start with, they were
using the Google Tag Manager--
you may be familiar
with this, if you
are using Firebase Analytics--
with the Cloud Firestore SDK
to write information back
into Cloud Firestore about
the user who visited the site.
This then triggers a couple
of different data pipelines
to process this data.
The first one is triggering
a Cloud Function that then
inserts the data into BigQuery.
This makes the whole
dataset available
to their recommendation
engine to do processing.
The second pipeline
that gets kicked off
with a Cloud Function is
using the Cloud Vision
API to process the image.
Now, this, I think,
is really interesting.
Because Guesswork deals with
so many different languages
out there, they found it more
reliable to use the Vision
API across the image of the
product to get metadata back,
than relying upon
the text metadata
and trying to
understand and process
all the different
variations of language.
So you get better,
more consistent results
by processing the
image of the product.
The recommendation then
uses this information
to take two paths.
The first one is
for anonymous users.
They write the recommendation
back into Firestore,
which gives a
real-time update out
to the client for that user.
For registered users, they
can send a periodic email
with the
recommendations to them.
So here is the whole
architecture on a single slide.
It's very simple,
but very powerful.
And this architecture
has allowed
them to move very
quickly and make changes.
So they can AB test
different algorithms
to improve their recommendations
and improve, obviously,
their revenue.
So one of the things that I
really love about this example
is Guesswork is a
company of three people
that they bootstrapped
using this technology.
And they now serve
100 million users.
So three people managed to
bootstrap a successful company
to serve 100 million
users using this tech.
That's all about the small
teams able to do big things.
And this is another example
I love, Hawkin Dynamics.
They're probably one of the
most interesting meetings
I've been on.
You'll see some
force plates on here.
We had a video
conference with them
and they were in the
back of the room jumping
up and down, doing
counter-movement jumps
on plates.
It's probably one of the most
energetic meetings I've had.
So Hawkin Dynamics is a
sports performance company
focused on providing
cutting edge
technology in both software and
hardware for athletic teams.
They optimize
athletic performance
by analyzing the information
from these force plates using
things like counter-movement
jumps and isometric tests.
And so let's have a quick look
at their architecture, which
is very simple.
And there's one little
bit I'll add in a minute,
but it really is
this simple for them.
So they've got force plates that
they give out to teams that,
at a very fine
grain level, measure
of the force of the
movements of the athletes.
This information is then
wirelessly transmitted
to the mobile apps--
whether it's a phone or a
tablet that Hawkin Dynamics has.
These apps work
offline because not
all the locations where
they're doing this test
has network connectivity.
On the app, they can
quickly review the raw data
that the force
plates has produced
and maybe get the athletes
to repeat the test
or look for something new.
When they are connected,
they use Firebase Auth
to authenticate in and
sync this information
into Cloud Firestore, which,
once again, kicks of Cloud
Functions to do the
processing on the raw data,
to pull out moving averages
and other information
that then they can display in
more depth in their mobile web
application.
So when they are
online, all of these
are kept closely in
sync with each other,
so you can see in real-time
what the results are.
They sent me a copy
of their data model
so we can have a quick look
and see how they structured.
And this uses some of the
collection and document
hierarchy that we provide
within Cloud Firestore.
So they have an
overall collection
called teams, where
all of the sports teams
they have live within.
And they have a document that
just has some basic information
about that team.
Under the team
document, each team
has a set of data,
the settings for how
they want to configure
the displays and the tests
that they have, the
actual raw data that
gets synced from the force
plates, the test, which
is a computed result that
comes from Cloud Functions,
and the different groups,
the different athletes
within those players
on that team exist.
So let's talk
about the athletes,
which has a document that
outlines a bunch of information
about when they were
tested using arrays,
what different groups they're
in, what their weight is,
et cetera.
And then under that is
that computed average doc,
so a player can go in and look
at their performance over time
and how they're improving
based on different training
schedules.
So with that, I want to
hand it back to Kathy,
to talk about how Google has
been using Cloud Firestore.
KATHY LI: Thanks, Dan.
So if you're looking
at this screenshot,
this page is probably, one
that you actually know and have
already interacted with.
It's the Google Cloud
Next conference Website.
Our developer friends
at the Nerdery
actually built the
web and mobile apps
for this event using
Cloud Firestore.
They, like many
developers often do, work
with existing systems
and storage solutions,
rather than building
from the ground up.
Even so, Cloud Firestore can
still work well in this case.
We'll first take a look at
some of their actual data
in Firestore to give an
example of how some application
data can be laid out.
And then we'll zoom
to the whole system.
This is a view of the Firestore
Data Viewer in the Firebase Web
Console.
And you can see there
are top level collections
for, in this case, events, with
documents for the Cloud Next
events in San Francisco,
Tokyo, and London.
And the latter two are
coming up in the fall.
It's a flexible data
model so your application
can write whatever you need.
In this case, there are
some metadata fields
on the individual
days of this event.
We also have some English
language subcollections
of all the content that you'll
see on the conference site,
such as the home page and
marketing copy, the event
sponsors, and the
filters that you
use to narrow down your view
of the day's programming.
Lastly, here are the
sessions in a subcollection,
with documents for every one of
the general sessions that you
might attend, including the
one we're sitting in right now.
There's the document
with a list of labels
for the topics, a room capacity.
And as you might
imagine, if the size
of the attendee
list for a session
reaches the room capacity,
then the application logic
will set the can reserve
Boolean field to false.
So now that you've seen a
view of some of the data,
how do the developers use
Cloud Firestore to improve
on the app from prior years?
Nerdery already works with
an existing third-party SAS
provider that specializes
in event management.
So they store all
the conference data,
such as sessions, speakers,
registrants, rooms, and map
data.
They can read
directly from here,
but since there's no
event-driven model
for responding to
changes in your data,
the app pulls this information
on the order of many minutes,
which in the past has led to
registrants quickly filling up
sessions on the day
of, and a slight delay
in showing that status.
Now, Nerdery copies
all of their event data
into Cloud Firestore, which they
use as a single source of truth
for all apps to read from.
They also wrote a custom
API served on Google App
Engine, which accepts
writes from clients,
such as a user
bookmarking a talk,
and handles transactions
to the third-party system.
Then the clients read
directly from Firestore
to display all the data
that you actually see.
Here's a view of
the whole system .
And we can contextualize
it with an interaction
that you've probably
already had.
When you first view
the conference website,
it loads all the session
and information on partners
and stuff from
Firestore, as well as
images and other static assets
from Google Cloud Storage.
Then when you want
to take an action,
like bookmarking a
panel discussion,
you'll log in using either
your Google account or email
address.
And the apps use Firebase
Auth to authenticate you.
Then when you register for
a session, such as this one,
the app makes an API call
out to the third-party system
to update the logged in
user's set of reserved events.
But it also immediately writes
that session metadata back
to Firestore.
This eliminates having to
poll on session availability,
so that as soon as an
event actually fills up,
its status will be displayed
as full to all the apps.
So thanks to the folks over
at Nerdery for building
the apps that we're
all using this week.
Now we want to show
you the scalability
and ease of use of
Cloud Firestore.
We have a demo that
illustrates how
a large number of
concurrently connected devices
can receive updates from and
write updates to Firestore.
This will be visualized shortly
in a Google-colored Firestore
logo display with pixels
that represent the end user
devices in each of
four colored quadrants.
Then to reflect the quadrants'
updated colors in real-time,
we'll use one of the major
features OF Firestore, which
is the ability to
listen for changes
at any node in your
data hierarchy.
So you'll see pixels
updating their color
as new color values are
written to the documents
for each quadrant.
If you want to see
this visualization,
please visit firepixels.app.
And also, hold up your device
to us when it's loaded.
I will do this as well.
So you should see something
kind of like this.
Awesome, seeing a
few following along.
Thanks, everyone.
Can we also transition
to the demo screen?
Here what we're
seeing is that we
imitate devices, which are
our clients, with Node.js
processes.
And every simulated
device gets assigned
a pixel in this entire grid,
totaling 40,000 pixels.
Essentially, 40,000
concurrently connected devices.
Making a quadratic of
pixels change color
is done by writing a new
value to the color field
in a document for each quadrant.
Then we set up the clients
to listen on the input
document for each quadrant.
And when it gets
written, they'll
read the new color
from the data snapshot
and write it back to the
pixel document in Firestore.
As the pixels' color
values are written,
you'll then see their
corresponding pixels
in the display change color.
Currently, you're seeing
some of these color changes
every handful of
seconds as there
are some automatic changes
happening, as well as people
probably playing with the
demo in the storage showcase
booth, which is on the ground
floor of this building.
So we can also
actually edit this--
or make the pixels and
quadrants change color ourselves
by writing the data.
And in order to do that,
let's actually bring up
the Cloud Console.
So here's a view of the
Cloud Console we're in.
We've navigated to the
Firestore Data Viewer.
And over here, you can
see the three collections
that we have for
the many devices.
These are numbered.
We have as many
simulated devices
as there are total spots with
an x and y-coordinate per
quadrant.
We have pixels that get
assigned to each device.
And each pixel is named
for its x and y-coordinate,
has a color which matches
the color of the input
document for the quadrant,
as well as a partition that's
used to parallelize and
speed up the UI updates,
and an updated time stamp.
And we can look at
the input collection.
So here are the documents zero
through three for all four
quadrants in the logo, with a
color that we can actually set.
So right now, this
quadrant zero is green.
Although, this-- something
about doing demos.
I'm going to check my phone real
quick to see if it's updated.
Let's see what happens when
we write this value directly
in the Data Viewer, where you
can view real-time updates
and modify your data.
Sorry for the hiccup.
So in this case, we actually--
If you're looking
at it on your phone,
you should see that
some of the quadrants
have pixels that
are mixed colors,
or individual pixels
that aren't all
the same color in the quadrant.
And usually, these
represent the devices
seeing that a new
value has been written
for the color for that quadrant.
And then, the clients
will asynchronously
pick up that update,
write their color back.
And this then gets
updated in the UI, which
is how you see different pixels
trickle into the new color
that they should be.
This will be going on
and you can actually
play with this demo on
a few mobile devices
at the storage showcase booth.
One thing we should be able
to see in the Data Viewer
is that if you change the
value of the input here,
the pixels should reflect
their respective quadrant,
because it has a listener
on the input field.
So here, say we set
the input to blue.
Then we go over to the
pixels, and it's now
been updated, whereas
it was red before,
if you had noticed that.
We changed this to green.
And then these values
should have-- oh,
are updating in real-time
in the Data Viewer.
And one other thing of
interest, especially
for people who are
writing applications
that use more complex
queries, and therefore,
need to configure indexes
to support those queries,
you can navigate over
to the Indexes section.
And here we have, in our case,
one composite index defined
on the pixels collection.
And two fields, which enables
a query use to load the UI.
And this is the new feature
under Single Field indexes,
where each project is
automatically configured
to have all of
their fields indexed
in ascending, descending,
and array contains modes.
But since you want to,
as a general pattern,
avoid indexing, monotonically
increasing or decreasing
values, in this case, we
have disabled indexing
on the fields that
represent time stamps--
last updated time stamps--
to make sure that our app
keeps performing smoothly.
Can we transition
back to the slides?
As an overview of how
this app is set up,
we have the devices simulated
as Node.js processes
running in Kubernetes
pods with separate pods
for each quadrant.
Each of those
processes then sets up
many pixels, each
associated with a device,
as well as setting up listeners
on the Firestore input
document that has the
color per quadrant.
We can change the
colors in the display,
either using a
controller app that you
can see-- it'll be on a pixel
phone app the demo downstairs--
or via just changing the
data directly in the Cloud
Console, which we just did.
This writes to Firestore,
which triggers more updates
for each pixel document.
Then with thousands of
pixels updating at once,
we use a Golang backend
app to send the new colors
to the Firestore logo display
using web sockets, which
for us is a workaround so
that the browser doesn't
try to process thousands
of updates at once.
But you can see that
Firestore does scale
to handle many reads
and writes in real-time.
To show this a little
more concretely,
here's a code snippet using
a key feature of Firestore,
which is the real-time updates.
We have, at the top,
references to the database
and each of the
collections in it.
And in our init
function, we actually
call this setup
listener for each spot.
This is per process
after we've spawned many.
We set up a listener
on the input document
per each of the four areas, such
that when that gets written,
we invoke our callback.
That grabs the data snapshot
and writes the new color value
to the pixel document, which
then gets rendered in the UI.
So there you have it.
We are using Firestore to
sync app state in real-time.
And it scales up to
tens of thousands
of concurrently
connected devices.
And you can have,
ultimately, millions
of clients using your app.
Now we'll hand it back
to Dan, to wrap up
with some considerations to keep
in mind as you build and grow
your Firestore apps.
DAN MCGRATH: Thanks Kathy.
So I want to just run through
a couple of quick points
to keep in mind when you're
building larger apps, before we
go into Q&A. And I will not try
to do any demo on conference
Wi-Fi.
So the first thing to
remember as we're learning,
we've used a lot of
customer applications
that are now part
of our test suite,
and stress tests, in particular.
So one thing to consider
when writing your application
is how do you write scale?
And so a couple of
guidelines that we have.
The first is for each
individual document,
try to keep the sustained
update rate to once per second.
So we do multi-region
replication
across data centers that are
geographically dispersed.
So there is some time of speed
of light considerations as part
of that.
You can, of course,
burst higher,
but if you do a sustained
rate, like 30 a second
for a long period of
time, eventually your app
will start to get a lot slower.
The other one which
Kathy mentioned
with monotonically increasing
and decreasing values
is keep the writes of those
types of data to around 500
per second.
When our system splits, we
do horizontal key ranges
and we split on either side
to have more service take
care of that load.
When you're just appending
data to the end of, say,
indexes or primary keys
or prepending data,
then all the load ends up
on one side of the split.
So we'll only ever
have one server taking
care of that load for you.
When you're using the native
mode, we support, at the moment
during beta, 10,000
writes per second.
When you're in
Datastore mode, we
support up to a million
writes per second.
And this is around the
real-time notification system
and whether that's
turned on or off.
When you're ramping
up your traffic,
so if you've got large
events that are happening,
we have a rule that we call the
555 rule, which is starting off
at 500 writes per second
and growing at 50%
every five minutes.
And for read, think
about 10x that.
The other thing that
you should consider
is how your concurrent
connections work.
So as your user base
scales, how are the number
of concurrent connections
that you have from your client
library going to scale?
So as a general
rule, we support up
to 1 million
concurrent connections
when you're doing one update
per second per connection.
So that's a million updates a
second across all your devices.
To put that in context, a
million concurrent users
is something like 10 to 14
million daily active users,
depending on the makeup
of your application.
The other thing to just keep
in mind is how much data
you're pushing out
to your clients
and generally, it's about
10 megabytes per second
across that list of clients.
[MUSIC PLAYING]